[Music]
oh hey by the way Frozen earlier you
said Fredo well well well well well well
well
look who has a show again
let's get after it
where you been
foreign
by the way on this new show not allowed
to sit not a lot he has to stand stand
first and most of it is I think it's
Newsmax right I don't think they can
afford shares news Nations they don't
have a lot of chairs thank you Chris
Cuomo is back in prime time and looking
to change the cable news game
when there's like a coffee machine like
visible on frame oh no no you're right
kidding it's not really is that what
dude you're right but they would though
that's a bad chroma key on him too Cuomo
right here on news nation and shaking up
nighttime cable news with a new Mission
and a pledge for transparency on the
issues that matter we need people in my
position to do more
to not just play or even referee the
game that is plaguing our politics and
Society Monday's Premiere by the way
keep in mind Bill O'Reilly's also on
news Nation
all the rejects that got like sexual
allegations go to this is what we need
we need a Bill O'Reilly Chris Cuomo show
oh my God like a Hannity and combs for
the Next Generation
I love it oh my God the two of them just
bickering two big stories to analyze for
you calling show
oh my God it's a calling show no you
know what that one it's Chris Cuomo
let's get after it oh my God shut up
look up I know you're kidding you're
wrong with Cuomo let's get after it
he's back he's [ __ ] back this makes
me so happy the amount of content we've
gotten out of Como has been amazing and
I'm so glad he's back on TV I cannot
tell you how exciting this is by the way
first off why is he dress like a black
preacher
exactly [ __ ] showing up in a [ __ ]
pimped out Suburban to the [ __ ]
Studio would you buy that from the NBA
analyst collection
[Laughter]
on Cuomo after hours
you're gonna call me and you're gonna
tell me what is the biggest ball
breaking moment you had this week yo how
do you know I got this from the Marv
Albert collection
hey Chris I got all my own moment today
all right give it to me pal so I was at
work today right yeah the post comes up
to me it's 4 55 in the afternoon he
tells me he's gonna come in tomorrow are
you kidding me ah wow man he's got
really breaking your balls
that's why we need a universal minimum
wage yo next caller
um
oh that's right he is dressed up as
Vince McMahon
Chris yeah this is uh this is uh Tony
from Queens yes so uh you know I came
home and my wife she didn't have dinner
prepared and you know I gave her like a
few hours notice I mean what's up with
that
here's what you gotta do listen uh Tony
here's what you do pal uh next time the
dinner's late you hit it with a sack of
oranges they don't leave a booze and the
cops won't ever know nothing you're on
the news you familiar you know they come
over like oh Chris we know you you're
like yeah you know how she is
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] poor Sam for me
hey Chris long time listen to first time
caller
I just want to wait how you think the
Eagles are going to do this yet
is getting random questions
[Music]
because like you know they won the Super
Bowl and it just seems like every year
after that they just get worse and worse
I'll hang up I want to listen to myself
that's the question I'm so excited for
this show because I know merch is
kidding kind of but this is what the
show's gonna be and it's gonna be
amazing hey Christmas you something uh
you think uh you think there's any
chance that uh they might go and
retroactively indict Trump for some
crimes that he did over 20 years ago
that's certainly possible
it's like
yeah
Chris what do you think about the
continued effort to the Ukraine uh you
know a lot of people are saying
zielinski's a war criminal and some
people say Putin's the bad guy I don't
really see a clear-cut good guy here
Chris can clarify things for me
oh
my thoughts on uh Kanye West's comments
about the Jews and also how did you
shake away an uh overbearing mother
[Music]
oh my God
oh [ __ ]
Oh I thought this was uh apropos I hope
I can find it uh quick and timely
fashion oh [ __ ] like I said Royce check
Show links right now this is actually a
thing oh my God thank you Jim
wait no
no
no
this for real
we were kit Marsh Marsh
you were kidding
all right we're fortunate to have the
one and only Bill O'Reilly with us
tonight he has a new book called killing
bro this is so awkward
oh this is so cool
this is so good the legends
now they pretend to be friends oh yeah
of course
killing the Legends full danger of
celebrity which is a really interesting
look not just at the men on the cover
that you were just looking at but
circumstances and how their deaths came
about and what how did your guys's
[ __ ] career death come about that's
what I want to know uh one of them was a
Serial sexual harasser and the other
one's brother Was a Serial sexual
harasser ah yes fair enough
but that honestly though I mean out of
all these guys Cuomo really is the one
that got [ __ ] the worst yeah he really
did he really did because it's like it
wasn't even like he did anything he just
was like I don't want to cover my
brother's sexual harassment stuff that
seems oh [ __ ] he's my brother
uh both that is common among all of them
and also common to us Bill thank you for
joining me
congratulations on the new gig Cuomo
don't scream he's hammered he's hammered
again bills again yeah but he's like
he's he's old man hammered which is a
different kind of hammered Cuomo don't
screw it up all right I'm trying thank
you that's why I got you how can I screw
it up so there's a little bit of
breaking news coming out here uh that a
an employee a former president Trump
says he was directed or they were
directed to move boxes after the
subpoena came in from one basement into
the Mar-A-Lago residence uh what matters
to you about this
is that Cassidy Hutchinson again is she
is he the one who do not know who it is
it's an anonymous source we do not know
who it is
another anonymous okay look if you want
to do this show
here's the thing you know what's funny
Marsh you know what I'm learning is that
guys like us we've been doing this [ __ ]
so long we know how to do a show over
with a slight delay in Zoom we've become
so used to it but watching these people
because they're not gonna fly these guys
into the same Studio you [ __ ] nuts
this is hallucinations suck my dick so
these guys who have absolutely no like
Zoom or Skype etiquette are just gonna
[ __ ] talk over each other for 40
minutes at a Brendan Shob each other for
this whole segment what do you think
about the employees it's our Trump
robots no but no no but no use you
the president then you and there'll be
long silence because they won't be so
rich B yeah that was so rich Papa
oh of course how much money you think
he's got
shut up Brandon the [ __ ] up
what does that make in the last six
years how many you think 35
000 Anonymous sources look all it is is
BS Cuomo unless it's a cross-examination
of it so I mentioned Miss Hutchinson who
said that somehow Donald Trump I feel
like it's noose Nation like the minor
leagues like when you when you get
caught like [ __ ] up they send you
back to news to news Nation these are
all Kenny Powers
to [ __ ] like learn the craft no
you're right though it's the AAA league
right because there's two groups of
people there right the burned out
Legends right that all had some kind of
controversy and then a Bunchy probably
young upstarts that are learning the
crafts as they [ __ ] like they're
learning oh you're right you're right
they're not staying at [ __ ] news
Nation they're not gonna stay there
making fifteen thousand dollars yeah
here they're like no I'm I'm learning
and then I'm gonna have this on my
resume I'm on my way out to a better
team you guys are just here to relive
Your Glory Days we used to put on a suit
and pretend like you're still on
television I liked it better when it was
called headline news like no no that was
like we used that was the version before
the internet [ __ ] headline news where it
would be like all right the up the up
starts and the guys going down headline
news guys
um